[Music]
hey Britta what you doing oh I'm just
getting ready for the super fun New
Year's party we're having tonight yeah
why don't we agree to a New Year's party
I don't know my god
Oh since we're all here we should have
Anita's passe the haters party suck yeah
I hate New Year's we could have this
glosses I say 2017 yes oh my god let's
do it the wine has betrayed us
oh I know I hate having to find someone
to kiss where why is it important that I
start my New Year's by putting my lips
on a stranger's lips hadn't thought
about that part
PAC I don't want to spend another New
Year's worrying about that I wish I
could just be like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah or it could be like make-a-wish it
already came true yeah watch a lot of
80s movies last week okay but our goal
is clear right really watch I think
somewhere I kiss at midnight your plan
is better yeah let's do that
[Music]
hey what'd you think of this oh I like
it
are you gonna wear tight let me see if I
have any you know I'm gonna be
optimistic and say that we're gonna have
a lot of fun tonight yeah as long as I
don't have to watch Jack and Bridget
make out for the 100th time dude you
have to tell her how you feel or I could
just suffer quietly like a masochist
that I am I really do hate seeing you
like this though this is too [ __ ] you
look the perfect amount of [ __ ] oh
good that's what I'm going for just a
little bit of [ __ ] okay but have you
talked to break it about how weird it is
that she's seen your ex oh I wanted to
but then I got busy and then I saw Jack
with this other girl and I just wanted
to full avoidance mode wait you know we
as a group are not great at
communication guys I'm through this uh
no no no no no no oh here look at this
[Music]
all right very funny funny
because I love that - oh hey Jack hey
Maddy yeah this is Jamie hi are you
gonna tell Bridget yeah tell her what
about that bye Jamie are you stalking me
no I'm not stalking you don't flatter
yourself okay look Bridget non-exclusive
does she know that well we've never had
the talks I think it's pretty clear okay
just tell her okay all right well okay
[Music]
yes abridges great oh my god I know
oh my god Rendell you're so funny but I
don't say anything again yeah so wait oh
my god she did the cutest thing this one
I had to tell you
[Music]
I will mom hey Matt wait what's
happening we're having a pretty anus the
worst night I took up with this guy and
he didn't want to when I'm with you my
one this guy hook up with you is he a
crazy person I know right I mean I like
good tonight dude New Year's always
sucks you can't put so much stake into a
single night yeah you're right I mean
I'm here watching the ball drop with my
parents so you're already having a
better night than me that's adorable
yeah it's so cute when they fall asleep
before midnight and I'm alone scrolling
through people's Instagram seeing their
cool parties benefit I gotta go me too
I'll take a shot for me
way ahead of ya Elliot come say goodbye
to your grandparents Bridget and Jack
are making out can we please do shots
yes
you know what I think I'm actually just
gonna call it a night I don't know you
have to say something
bedroom oh I'll go grab paper towels oh
my god checks is my butt like a bullet I
was trying to show what I'm drunk I love
him what kind of fill out my mouth I
think I am in love with you damn it
Bridget don't go okay why are you doing
this look I know I'm supposed to talk to
you about me and Jack White I just
didn't what's not about Jack okay it's
about you and me you're making her
miserable you're not making me miserable
yeah how do you must--you that she's in
love with you and he's per age at her
house hey there's no effects gene is
that true medicine said Jack is cheating
on you
[Applause]
[Music]